alright guys bangbang
I'm super excited about this I feel like
we are going to one explain what the
hell the Federal Reserve is and why it's
important and then we can get into all
the nuances of this crazy chaotic
economic time that we're in so much for
doing this man hey Anthony how's it
going doing all right how are you you're
San Diego right I am doing great it's
it's getting beautiful here again so I'm
hoping that I'm hoping what they say
about this weather thing is true this
stupid virus that you know the nicer
weather kind of has at least a little
bit of a positive impact on everything
so absolutely so for those that don't
know who you are let's start with
background and kind of what you've done
in your career and then we can get to a
lot of the stuff that's happening now
yeah gosh I mean I started my career at
Merrill so kind of started a big big
brokerage firm managed a lot of money on
a big team there left the firm I just
didn't agree with you know a lot of the
philosophy of the big firms and ran a
hedge fund basically for like six years
during the financial crisis and and in
the last like I mean really did what
happened with my career was odd in that
coming out of the financial crisis I
wrote a lot of research about what the
Fed was doing and basically mostly what
quantitative easing was what all these
big programs were and what they might
the impact they might have on the bond
markets primarily and I ended up doing a
lot of like non-discretionary portfolio
management for big banks and and
portfolio managers who were trying to
basically navigate the interest rate
environment cuz back then a lot of the
work that I was doing a lot of the
research I was doing was kind of
counterintuitive to the a lot of the
mainstream narratives I was basically
saying back then that QE would actually
cause a little bit of deflation that it
would make interest rates go down so it
was a lot of it was kind of counter
and luckily I ended up being you know
mostly right but uh my whole career kind
of transformed coming out of the
financial crisis because of that and so
my focus now is mainly conservative sort
of fixed income based portfolios really
still focused on trying to help people
navigate the interest rate environment
going forward which is only gotten you
know more and more difficult so yeah so
let's talk about 2008 Oh nine crisis
first and then we'll get to kind of
what's going on now so in 2008 obviously
there was the housing crisis the
government stepped in created a ton of
monetary stimulus every single person
who's ever read any economics book
immediately says if they print a bunch
of money
we're gonna go to inflation maybe even
hyperinflation right do you think that
QE potentially could cause deflation and
how does that actually work from a
mechanism standpoint well it was
interesting back then I actually knew a
bunch of guys that worked friends of
mine family friends and a couple of
other friends that worked in Tamura in
Japan and it was interesting when they
first started ramping up all these big
programs I started talking to these guys
in Japan because they had been doing QE
for like 15 years at this point so kind
of trying to go back through history and
trying to understand it it's sort of an
operational level I talked to these guys
and they're basically like look this
thing doesn't do any of the stuff that a
lot of the mainstream narratives imply
it doesn't it's not like printing money
it doesn't make inflation go up it won't
necessarily make the stock market go up
their argument basically was that it is
marginally deflationary because what
they're basically doing the Fed is
creating money okay so they're creating
central bank reserves and basically
swapping though they're purchasing a
like a Treasury bond or a
mortgage-backed security from the
private sector and what that basically
is is it's a clean asset swap basically
the the Fed prints a reserve
slops it for a treasury bond but the
crucial thing is that they take the
Treasury bond out of the private-sector
economy so it's almost as if the
Treasury bond has been unprinted to some
degrees the Fed takes it and puts it on
their balance sheet and the Fed's
balance sheet is it's like a black hole
it's just this nebulous thing that
doesn't exist in the real economy I mean
we could see the accounting of it it's
there but it's not like the Fed isn't
going to Walmart and buying things with
their balance sheets so it's like it's
almost like they take the money out of
the or the Treasury bonds out of the
private sector and they bury them in the
backyard or something but the kicker
with it was that what they're really
doing when they do this is they're
taking interest income out of the
private sector and so the private
sectors incomes actually go down so in a
sense it's kind of like it's like
they've swapped a checking account for a
savings account expecting there to be
like some sort of big rush to go you
know now you use your your new checking
account to go buy goods and services so
the whole the whole program in my view
is sort of misguided and I'm you know
it's funny I I know you're a critic of
the Fed and but I'm I'm weirdly also a
critic of the Fed in the sense that I
basically think that the Fed and a lot
of what it does is not nearly as
impactful or important as a lot of the
mainstream narratives make it seem so to
the Fed to me it engages in a lot of
this funny business with the economy
that doesn't really do all the things
that a lot of people seem to think it
does so ok this is interesting right
because I actually think that we may
agree on the funny business my
perspective is just like they shouldn't
do it I think your perspective is like
hey they're doing it but it doesn't have
the impact everyone thinks it has would
it be fair to say that you agree they
should do it or you're in the camp up
they should not be doing that stuff
it does depend I think but like I would
have said in in 2008 I actually thought
that QE one what
somewhat important in that what they
were doing was they were really trying
to shore up the banking system and the
banking system was such a cluster at
that point that you needed to do
something because the I mean that's the
feds primary purpose and I think this is
another thing that some people I think
misunderstand about the Fed that the Fed
is basically just clearing house so they
clear payments for banks there the
banker for the banking system basically
and in periods like 2008 the banking
system starts to shut down and that
becomes problematic because if me and
you can't clear a payment because
JPMorgan and Bank of America are scared
of each other then it causes all these
negative knock-on effects that you know
like your business could start to fail
or you know potentially shut down for
periods of time just because the banks
are scared of each other and that's it's
idiotic the way that you know they can
even happen so the Fed is just basically
a public Clearing House that is it's
always open they never shut down so when
JPMorgan and Bank of America gets scared
of each other the Fed comes in and says
don't worry about it we're gonna clear
payments and we're gonna make sure or
that Anthony and Cullen don't go out of
business just because the Bank of
America and JP Morgan are idiots and
scared of each other so that's the feds
primary role and they do all this other
stuff that is sort of tangentially
supportive of the banking system but
isn't really always necessary like I
would say that qe2 qe3 all the other
iterations I would say even though the
version they're doing now probably a big
waste of time um probably not having a
very big impact on anything really and
probably to some degree not necessarily
a waste of money but sort of an
unimportant or or you know a waste of
energy to some degree just because there
are things that they can do to support
the economy and QE just isn't one of the
things that's very effective so I think
that a lot of people understand you know
central bank's basically have these two
right they can manipulate interest rates
and they can print money or quantitative
easing and it's like over the last you
know really kind of twelve years or so
but but even a little bit before that
the idea of quantitative easing has not
only become accepted
we went from emergency measures to now
it's hey this is part of what they're
going to do at certain times and I guess
the big question most people have right
so some of the listeners have zero clue
how the Fed actually quote-unquote
prints money and then injects it into
the economy you talked a little bit
about that maybe just explain the actual
mechanism of injecting that liquidity
and then we can get to the impact of
what that does to an economy in times of
recession Airy periods yeah
well the Fed in its simplest manner is
just a really big bank and banks have
the ability to create money from thin
air literally so if you and I go into a
bank and we get a loan that bank doesn't
it they don't create the new loan by
having deposits necessarily or
multiplying their deposits or anything
like that they're literally creating a
new loan agreement from thin air and so
that deposit alone creates a deposit
from thin air and it's only backed by
whatever the agreement underlying that
is that we have some income and maybe
some assets that are backing the loan or
whatever it is but they belong itself
and the deposit the new deposit that is
created is created from thin air it is a
new financial asset and a new financial
liability for each of us and so the
entire feed of the entire economy grows
a little bit when that loan is made the
Fed does the same basic thing there they
basically just create these these
financial agreements from thin air we're
in the the kicker would the Fed is they
have all these private banks that are
basically required to make markets for
them so when the when the New York Fed
goes out and they start implementing
quantitative easing they win and they
basically order
primary dealers who are the big banks
that basically make markets for the for
the Fed they are basically ordering them
to go out and purchase bonds and the Fed
is giving them reserve deposits creating
reserve deposits within the banking
system and the banks are basically going
in and buying the bonds and swapping
those bonds with the new deposits that
the reserves result in so the Fed sort
of forces the private banking system to
be its market maker and that's how they
create all this new money that ends up
basically being swapped for the Treasury
bonds got it and so I think that right
now the general idea that people have in
their mind whether they're right or not
is okay we had the coronavirus which is
a health crisis that then led to a lot
of fear uncertainty and kind of this
liquidity crisis everyone sold off
assets because they wanted dollars right
so you get a strengthening dollar you
get asset prices that fall the Fed then
has to step in and try to stabilize
markets and drive a recovery right and
the way that they've done that is
obviously they dropped interest rates
and then they basically came in with
these monetary you know really bazookas
if you will where they just started say
hey we're gonna print trillions of
dollars right and there's two schools of
thought one is in the short-term
medium-term we're gonna stay in a
deflationary environment and that
deflationary environment will suck up
all the liquidity and we there's no
chance of hyperinflation or really any
inflation the second school of thought
is you can't print trillions of dollars
without causing inflation how do you
evaluate the merits of those two
arguments and do you agree or disagree
that that is kind of the number one
debate in finance right now
Oh for sure I think the impact of all of
this is the the most hotly debated thing
going on weirdly I increasingly find
that people seem to have this view that
it's virtually impossible for the
government to create inflation I think
that we sort of haven't burned in our
brains after you know the impact of the
the financial crisis and just falling
interest rates and
for 30 years and you know ever rising
national debt that the everyone sort of
seems to be in this mindset that we we
somehow can't create inflation and I
think there's kind of two things going
on here
there's the feds programs and then
there's the Treasury programs and
they're in my mind they're distinctly
different things because I think a lot
of people think that they have this view
of the Fed where they think the Fed has
to finance the Treasury spending and I
just don't I don't really think that
that's very accurate the the Treasury
the way that the Treasury decides to
finance its spending it doesn't really
matter in my view whether they took the
Treasury could literally if they if they
wanted to change some rules in Congress
the Treasury could go out and print all
the money they wanted to I mean that the
actual printing press is in the Treasury
it's part of the Bureau of Engraving so
it's not even part of the Federal
Reserve to begin with the Fed just kind
of distributes the money that Treasury
creates so if the Treasury wanted to
just go out and dump a trillion dollars
in the middle of Constitution Avenue
they could go do that they don't have to
sell bonds under the current existing
structure of the way that the the
legality of this the institutions were
we technically have to finance it by
selling bonds but to me in this
environment there's no lack of demand
for bonds in this environment especially
the way that they're financed because
most of them the bonds are basically
bills so you're basically in my mind the
difference between a Treasury bill and a
US dollar is very very minimal there's
no signs of a lack of demand for
Treasury bills if anything I think that
given that the the US dollar is the
reserve currency there's an extremely
high demand for liquidity and bills and
currency in general so the whole
financing narrative to me is kind of
incorrect and it's important I think to
understand that because the that what
the Treasury is doing is humongous and
potentially inflationary the way that
they're running
they're spending programs with a four
trillion dollar deficit Pelosi
introduced a new three trillion dollar
bill today I mean you could be talking
about $7 or six seven trillion dollar
deficit this year that's those are huge
huge numbers and so I think over the
course of the last you know six weeks or
so a lot of people have been focused on
the feds lending programs which are
they're mostly trying to support the
banking system for the most part and I
think a lot of people missed the fact
that well the Fed was doing some big
stuff the Treasury was doing arguably
even bigger stuff and that's where I
think the risk of inflation if there's
going to be a risk of inflation going
forward that's where it's gonna come
from it's gonna come from the Treasury
not the Fed so if I remember the numbers
correctly I think that we were targeting
like a trillion and a half dollar
deficit going into the year or that was
kind of the the general thought then
once you get all the stimulus now it's
like oh we might get three and a half to
four trillion if they do more stimulus
that could run up as you said to six or
seven trillion dollars one of the big
questions is just like is it actually
debt if you don't have a plan or an
intention to pay it off like how do you
think about that deficit and in the
national debt well that's one of the
weird things I mean the so you have two
sides of a balance sheet here and in a
healthy normal economy the private
sectors balance sheet is always growing
so the assets are always growing and the
liabilities are growing there's nothing
inherently bad about debt in and of
itself I mean if you're if you're out
there borrowing and you're investing it
in things that are productive and
innovative and you know really useful
sources of production then there's
nothing inherently wrong with creating
debt to do that I think the the thing
that people tend to sort of generalize
about is that things like like a high
credit card debt is a revolving type of
debt like that is is terrible in the law
because it's just it suffocates you
there's no way anybody can invent
anything really that or is certainly an
aggregate that is gonna be able to
consistently pay off like a 20% credit
card bill so I think a lot of consumers
have it in their mind that that debt is
always bad and the reality is that a lot
of debt is actually very productive that
a lot of debt is used for good purposes
and it helps create the assets that make
the whole economy basically functioning
and sustainable in the long run I mean
the the whole reason the dollar is the
reserve currency is because for the most
part you have businesses and US
consumers and households have been
incredibly innovative and productive
over the you know the history of the
United States and so we've used money in
a very innovative and resourceful way
that has created you know the most
output of any country in the entire
global economy ever and so that's the
main reason why the the dollar is the
reserve currency and it's why there's so
much demand for dollars especially in
times like right now because it's it's
backed by you know twenty five trillion
dollars of output that is relatively
safe compared to everybody else's
resources and so it's all it's all kind
of intertwined in this in this sort of
complex way and what's weird about what
the government does that is so different
from what the private sector does is
that the government debt also grows in
aggregate over time you look at the like
a trend of like household debt it never
goes down really in the long run it
should always go up I mean how also debt
should basically always go up because
the the households assets will also go
up in the long run so in the long run
the the economy's total financial assets
and total financial liabilities will
basically be ever-increasing the big
kicker with the difference between
private sector debt and government debt
is that private sector debt can sort of
be creatively destroyed at times like
during the financial crisis you had a
lot of you basically had a big debt boom
so he had this sort of big real estate
inflation
and in the reactor because in two large
do graffiti banks created too much money
it chased too few homes you had this big
boom
but then the kicker is that thing
deflates over time that doesn't always
happen with the government because the
government oftentimes isn't actually
allowing any sort of market mechanism
there's no competitive force that forces
the government to like pay down its
debts over time so that's why this is
such a weird environment in my mind is
because the government is basically
going to print you know create four five
six trillion dollars of new financial
assets and liabilities that aren't
necessarily supported by anything new
there are even new houses being
supported by all of this so this money
is being created out of thin air and
being spent and financed and it's
basically we're basically just paying
people to sit around and do nothing for
the most part to stay home literally so
it's a really weird environment to think
about just because the you have all
these supply chains that are being cut
off and the basic you know math of like
you know any basic monetarist view of
supply and demand here is that you
inevitably there I don't see how there
can't be some inflation that comes out
of this I'm not you know I'm not like
transitioning into like a hyperinflation
sort of mentality but I don't see how
there's any chance that coming out of
like say 2021 or 2022 that if the
economy is really rebounding that we
don't have three four five percent
inflation and I think you could have the
Federal Reserve chasing their own tail
raising rates and trying to catch up
with all this stuff way after the fact
so yeah what's interesting I guess is so
if we go back to the deficit for a
second there's almost this element of
like at the same time that
they're going to drastically increase
the national debt they're also going to
lose on revenue as well so you see this
much more at the state and local level
obviously but even at the federal level
there is some lost revenue there because
just Commerce has stopped right and so
it almost exasperates the debt that is
being issued because you're just adding
to a deficit by simply just a piano
standpoint you're literally taking off
one side and while raising the other
side to some degree right totally I mean
so that's that's weirdly it's actually a
big part of economists would call it
automatic stabilizers what happens as
the business cycle kind of ebbs and
flows over time is a big part of
government support during downturns is
that governments run bigger deficits in
part because their tax revenues declined
so their revenues declined and their
spending increases at the same time so
you see this in a huge way right now and
especially with the way that the Kerr's
Act was structured that the government's
running these you know $2,400 a month of
extra uninsurance benefits or
unemployment benefits and so what's
happened now is that not only yes the
government's tax revenue is falling but
the the spending is going way up because
it sort of naturally does because more
people just demand unemployment benefits
and things like that so you know over
course of a natural business cycle you
typically will get the government's
deficit will shrink over time because
tax revenues rise even if spending stays
stagnant the tax revenues rising alone
will create a smaller and smaller
deficit and then you get this explosion
in an event like this and so there's
sort of a natural ebb and flow and and I
would argue that you know to a large
degree you know I don't want to give
people the impression that I think that
all of this is bad I mean I think I
actually think that when the government
imposes a lock down on most of the
private sector economy I think they have
a responsibility to to pay people to
some degree to continue to be able to
survive and you can't you can't tell
everybody that the economy
is now closed and locked down you're not
allowed to go do all this stuff and oh
yeah and your economy is effed also oh
so I think the government has some
responsibility the really interesting
thing with this is and this is the thing
that I think nobody really can answer at
this point is how long will this thing
last how so and the kicker there is how
deflationary is this thing gonna be
because if this thing lasts for like six
more months or twelve more months and
everyone sort of locked down for that
period you're gonna have a really
devastating economic impact because of
the whole financial system it's just not
designed for people to for instance not
be able to pay their rents for like
three or four months in a row and you
start having this big knock-on effect
over time where you're not just gonna
see the banking system start to kind of
buckle you're gonna see almost
everything start to buckle to some
degree because the whole financial
system is based on to a large degree
these short-term financial contracts
these short-term debt contracts that
they need to be serviced
you can't go three four five six months
without servicing these things without
big knock-on effects and so I think the
whole inflation deflation debate still
comes down to how long does this thing
last if it if the lockdown is really
over and this thing is really starting
to go away as it kind of looks like it
might be at this point then I think you
have a serious chance of three four five
percent inflation in the next few years
that the Fed is going to be chasing to
grapple with whereas if this thing lasts
for another six to twelve months all
inflation bets are off the government
won't be able to spend enough money to
offset the hugely deflationary effect of
all the defaults yes there's there's a
number of things there that I think are
super interesting the first is there's
this a lot of theory or just a framework
that I used to think about that I called
the economic circle of life right is the
whole idea of like you know take
manufacturing somebody creates the raw
good
they then put it to a supplier that
supplies the goods to a business the
business sells it to an individual or a
customer they're able to then pay their
rent to a bank and kind of the financing
of the raw goods and you just have this
circular kind of component to the
economy and when the government steps in
and mandates a shutdown of the business
what a lot of people understand is hey
there is a downstream effect right all
of a sudden I can't sell goods to a
customer right and I can't pay my rent
and kind of all of those issues that go
downstream but also there's also an
upstream effect it's almost like a dam
in a river right because now all of a
sudden your suppliers got nobody to sell
to they can't go actually buy the raw
goods anymore and you you get kind of a
bi-directional impact by simply shutting
down or breaking that chain of that
circle and so to me it feels like that's
what the government is trying to solve
for right they're stepping in and
they're saying look I'm gonna give you
PPP loans so you can pay some employees
and trying to save jobs I'm also gonna
give stimulus checks I'm gonna beef up
unemployment like they're trying to
almost triage the problem where it
happens but if they don't do that
successfully in the short term the
problem in spreads across the entire
financial system and will never be able
to kind of fix the problem right yeah I
mean I that's where this all starts to
get really interesting is I think as a
as a sort of like short-term almost a
bridge loan there was a lot there's it
makes a lot of sense for the government
to be I think highly involved in the
short term they shut down the economy
and they basically tell everybody they
can't operate and they say look we're
gonna create a bridge basically here so
that people will at least be able to
sort of get by in this short term but
the longer this thing goes on the just
more and more damaging it all becomes
for the the aggregate economy and the
less and less effective the government
response is going to become I mean they
can't you just you cannot prop up the
entire economy just by paying people not
to do anything because again you get
back to that fundamental problem of you
have to
resources an output that supports any
monetary system and if you don't have
that then you know you operate in a lot
of ways like a third world economy does
well there a lot of third world
economies have problems with high
inflation not just because they have
sort of corrupt governments but in large
part because they just don't have the
underlying productive base to support
the the increases in the finances that
you often see in these countries and so
the more the longer and longer that this
thing goes on and you're just sort of
you know not producing the same quantity
of stuff but you're just sort of trying
to I mean to some degree fictitiously
prop everything up I just I don't see
how that doesn't have an inflationary
impact in the long run uh-huh
so I but it's funny I think we're
getting to that point where people I
think we're starting to realize that
maybe there isn't ever gonna be a
vaccine for this thing or maybe this
thing is just gonna be part of our lives
for the rest of our lives I don't know
if it's gonna maybe be some sort of
seasonal thing or are these sorts of
viruses gonna be something that you know
occur more or often I think people are
starting to kind of consider that and
say look to some degree we we're at the
point where we now start to we need to
start weighing the economic impact of
all of this which is very very real and
very very hurtful to millions and
millions of people versus the reality
that having any sort of functioning
economy is going to have trade-offs and
some of those trade-offs are that people
die in car accidents driving to work and
you know people get injured at work and
things like that and if you have a
monetary economy like we do that is the
center of all of our lives if you start
to get to the point where we're all sort
of thinking you know okay this thing
might be around for a lot longer than
any of us are comfortable with then it
starts to become pretty reasonable for
people to start saying okay we can do
this methodically and reasonably but a
lot of us need to start
back to life and producing stuff how do
you think about and I'll kind of at this
I know that this is highly controversial
for a lot of people right but but I do
think it's an important conversation how
do you think about almost like the math
equation between the loss of life and
the economic impact and I've seen people
do everything from you know hey there's
a equation of how many jobs lost in
exchange for you know the save a saving
of one potential life I've seen things
around GDP I've seen people try to say
well if you have X number of people
unemployed we know numbers around
suicide and and all that kind of stuff
just how do you think about that and and
fully understanding like this is a
moving target because the information
every day feels that we're getting new
information yeah
I don't know man I mean that is I could
get in trouble in a lot of ways
answering this question I'm cat and I'm
completely caveat in the conversation
because I actually don't think that
there's a right answer it's more of like
don't I don't not looking for an answer
more of like what is the mental yeah
yeah I don't know I I get it I am it's
funny I've been trying to work through a
way to write about that without I mean
cuz here's the thing I mean when someone
dies I mean it's just it's obviously
it's so tangible and it's real and
there's you know when someone is
depressed or just you know down on life
you know it's harder to quantify what is
that the impact of that to society and
also it's in a weird way the this
question is kind of like asking you know
have living standards increased in the
last 50 years you know I would argue
that in a lot of quantifiable ways
they've they've surged but in a lot of
other quantifiable ways or
non-quantifiable ways they've they've
gone down so it's - a lot of people it
just depends on your perspective I think
that the that we're we're getting to a
point I think in this whole crisis where
the the economic impact
so far has not been that great in that
the I think that the government has been
able to build this bridge so far goldman
sachs put out a real i tweeted this out
the other day that uh Goldman Sachs says
disposable income in in q2 and q3 is
going to be positive so the government's
aggregate impact so far they've floated
most of the economy so far and they will
through q3 so in the short term the
economic impact isn't that enormous but
i think the longer and longer this goes
the more and more this is going to start
and feel like an actual depression and
the more more it starts to feel like
that the more and more people are going
to start to realize that yet fifty a
hundred million people out of work
is that is a quantifiable hugely
disastrous multi-decade damaging type of
event that will have a meaningful impact
that is maybe not the equivalent of
people dying but is at least very very
comparable to the way that we're all
gonna perceive our living standards
going forward yeah i want to clarify one
thing basically what you're arguing is
the economic impact yes there's 30 plus
million people who lost their jobs and
kind of all of those quantifiable things
but the government basically stepped in
with like a life raft right and they
said hey look we're going to mitigate
the actual impact on you yes you lost
your job but here is unemployment plus
an extra six hundred dollars here's a
stimulus check you know here's the PPP
loan these various kind of programs that
they're putting in place for an
individual it may not completely
mitigate it but it at least allows them
not to go from i was employed to now i
have zero income right and that's where
you're getting some of that blunting of
the economic impact
exactly yeah so they're you know they're
providing i mean in a lot of ways it's
sort of like a temporary universal basic
income is what they're doing so there
I mean again they're they're telling
people to stay home they're giving
people a paycheck a lot of people are
gonna make more money on the
unemployment benefits than they were
before so yeah they're kind of floating
the economy in the short term with the
hope that this thing subsides and that
we can kind of get back to to living
lives by you know q4 and the the early
part of next year what like let's talk
about that a little bit right because
I've heard this number of times and the
math that I've seen at least definitely
checks out that there is a a good
portion of unemployed that are now
making more on unemployment than they
would have if they had kept their job
and how do you think about one the
ability for the government basically to
say okay go back to your job where you
make less money and to how does that
change the incentive structure because
to me it's almost like does that say
more about our unemployment benefits or
more about you know the the compensation
that people received before they were
unemployed right well this thing only
lasts till July 31st the the extra of
the federal the $2,400 that they're
giving an extra unemployment benefits
per month um so I don't know I think it
was like the Hoover Institution or
somebody I can't remember who
Brookings or somebody wrote a a piece
saying that this was gonna have a hugely
negative impact on the economy and I
don't know I honestly I kind of think
that's bogus in that I don't think
there's a lot of people who are who are
going to quit their jobs to get $2,400
until July 31st with the certainty that
when August first rolls around they're
not gonna have any money coming in so
but that there is a weird thing where
the longer and longer the government you
know sort of guarantees everything if I
find it hard to believe that the
incentive structure doesn't change
assuming they do that is for the
long-term but so as long as the as long
as the programs are short-term I don't
think that there is a huge change in the
incentive structure just because I don't
think any rational person
is quitting their job just to get you
know 600 bucks a week from the
government for two or three months where
is that line right so like one of the
things I've thought a lot about is if
they had my theater proposal at some
point to pay $2,000 a month every month
until we respected EP levels that were
pre-pandemic level and so that could be
literally two or three years of every
single American getting basically a ubi
check right I didn't call whatever they
want but very much down the path of vbi
is that a three months and if they have
a kind of a hard stop date we're still
okay six months twelve months like how
far can they go before they kind of run
off the cliff and then it becomes a
thing that you can't take back I don't
know I mean that's it's funny you know I
get in a lot of arguments with people
like mmt people who are job guarantee
advocates and you know in andrew yang
advocates who or ubi defenders and i
think what's so weird about a lot of
these programs is that we don't really
have any evidence to support you know
the long-term impact of all this stuff
meaning me personally I find it hard to
believe that you could you can implement
something like a job guarantee or ubi
and have no inflationary impact or no
change in incentive structures I just
don't see how that makes sense I mean if
you could make if you can make a living
wage and you could earn something you
know like median income or 60 70 80
grand a year with you know like
government health care packages and
stuff like that I don't see how that
doesn't change the long-term incentive
structure and meaningfully alter the
potential course of inflation and that's
the that's the big kicker I think you
know a lot of people we didn't touch on
this earlier but one of my big views is
that your governments don't run out of
money especially big governments that
have big underlying and productive
economy
like the United States the United States
is not gonna run out of money so this
the whole idea of the government sort of
financing and spending through bonds is
is sort of misleading the government
finances its spending by having
non-government creditors and we finance
the government basically at the rate of
inflation the rate of inflation is the
cost of the government doing its own
business and so that's the important
factor going forward it's not can the
government afford to spend six trillion
dollars but of course the government can
afford to spend I mean they can afford
it in a in the sense that they they can
create the money you know you and I
can't just go out and create six
trillion dollars tomorrow there's no
bank that's gonna take the other side of
that trade the government has its own
bank that's gonna take the other side of
that trade and so financing it from uh
you know do they have the money
perspective is obviously true I mean
they can finance they can finance a
hundred trillion dollars tomorrow they
wanted to Treasury could print it up and
dump it on the on the street the the
kicker is what is the cost of that in
real terms what is gonna be the
inflationary impact of that and that's
the that's the thing that is really hard
to wrap your head around because it's
it's funny especially in the last like
10 20 years you know especially
mainstream econ we just sort of have
this view that like you know you create
more money it creates more inflation and
you know more money chases you know more
goods or fewer goods or whatever and you
get inflation and that's the basic gist
of it in the last 20 years 30 years the
government has run ever perpetually
higher deficits and debt the Japanese
government is spending you know colossal
amounts of money trying to offset their
deflation and disinflation and they
haven't been able to do it to a large
degree and so I think the weird thing is
I don't think anybody really knows what
causes inflation or inflation is just so
much more complex than a lot of people
seem to make it out to be and it's not
just this
simple mechanism where the Fed creates
you know some money through QE
or the Treasury runs a deficit and you
automatically get inflation so I want to
talk about a couple of very extreme
examples right and I'll start kind of on
two different ends of the spectrum
there's a lot of people that would say
great the federal government can print
as much money as they want they should
do that they're kind of centrally
planned type economy print as much as
you need spend it how you see fit and
help us be economically stable but if
you can print your own money why do I
pay taxes right it's kind of like remove
one side of the balance sheet if you
will or your P&L and on the other side
just like go at it I'm assuming that you
disagree one with that and also too it's
the long term effect which is kind of
how do you think about that extreme
argument and then we'll flip around and
talk about the other side of it yes so
this is like one of the big pieces of
like the MMT narrative that i think is
very very wrong this idea that they they
like to claim the taxes don't fund
spending that because the government has
a printing press that they they don't
need underlying revenue sources and I
just think they're kind of playing war
games with a lot of this I think the the
tax revenue that a government generates
is a function of its output okay and any
underlying economy needs output in order
to have viable money the only reason if
people want money is because they really
want the stuff that they can get with
money they don't really want the money
they really want the stuff that money
gives them access to and so you need the
stuff to make the money valuable you
know you can't that it's putting the
cart before the horse to get that
backwards and so in terms of the the
government and its tax revenues the
government needs tax revenues because it
needs underlying output that generates
the income that makes everything
valuable so it's like
you know I'd like to think of the
government basically like a big bank the
the government can create money from
thin air just like a regular bank can
but the the bank needs underlying assets
and income in order to be viable
otherwise nobody would trust that Bank
the bat bank would have no creditors and
the government is really similar in that
the government needs to have underlying
resources and income to stuck-on degree
that and make everything viable that
makes everything work and supports the
underlying credit issuance
because that's what the government
really does the government isn't just a
big issuer of credit and the essential
aspect of credit is that people need to
just something degree believe that that
credit is valuable in the long term
otherwise there's no reason for them to
want to hold it in when you have an
economy that starts to produce less or
just over the time starts to sort of
stagnate and doesn't have the underlying
productive resources the credit system
becomes inherently less valuable to the
people who are using it and you what
happens is you get a lower demand for
money which results in an increase in
the rate of inflation
so we then flip to the other side
there's a bunch of people who would
argue the government is full of people
who have no clue what they're doing and
they should allow the free market to
reign don't step in don't intervene let
boom and bust cycles occur and your
intervention is actually causing bigger
problems yeah and so quantitative easing
is not needed and kind of all of the
other programs how do you think through
that argument I there's some truth to
that
and it's probably there's probably too
many generalizations like going back to
the earlier example of why the why the
Fed is a thing capitalist economies with
private banking systems are for the most
part over the course of an entire
business cycle very efficient I mean
banks are
much much better issuers of credit and
they have to compete and they have to be
you know diligent about how they issue
money because it has to be profitable in
the long run and they have you know
constraints that they have to be able to
meet and so private banks are for the
most part very very good things because
they they're kind of they oversee the
credit issue it's in the economy in a
competitive manner in a way that the
government doesn't or would not do if
the government was running the whole
banking system the problem with private
banking is that during periods like 2008
or you know the thing that really kicked
off the feds creation with the panic of
1907 when the whole banking system
crashed and the interbank system really
crashed the clearing houses crashed and
that created this big knock-on effect
that created a great big depression
basically because again the banks were
scared of each other and it had all
these knock-on effects that were super
negative and that that just doesn't make
any sense so so banks in these very like
acute situations are bad at operating a
banking system basically and it doesn't
make sense to how that banking system to
exacerbate everything into a depression
just because they get scared of each
other so the feds core operational
exists reason for existing to me makes a
lot of sense that in appear like the
2008 the Fed did basically its core job
really well all the tangential stuff the
the changing interest rates and the QE
stuff that was all tangential to the
fact that they actually kept the banking
system really liquid so they made sure
that you you mean your businesses didn't
fail because JPMorgan and Bank of
America couldn't clear a payment so that
core function is really essential and I
think that the the government has you
know a lot of very operations that it
does well because capitalists aren't
willing to do everything all the time
like we're not
capitalists aren't willing to
necessarily put out fires because
putting out fires isn't very profitable
it's hard to make money you know putting
your employees at risk in that way and
getting people to collectively pay
insurance to to pay for a fire
department and stuff like that your war
is the same sort of thing the war has an
inherently negative net present value
because it it's expensive to build
things that get blown up and you know go
out and kill your workforce it's hard to
make money running an operation like
that so capitalists don't want to do
these things that have a sort of
negative net present value and I think
those are the those are the instances
where government makes a lot of sense
the government can do these things that
a free-market economy just it doesn't
have the incentive structure to do it
because it's just too damn hard to make
money doing those things but the where I
think the government sometimes over
stuffs its boundaries is where it tries
to you know start to do things that
start to sort of impact the positive net
present value business structure of the
real economy in a way that starts to
alter it to a degree that has the
negative long term impact and I think
that you know it's it's funny like going
back to interest rates like I think that
for the most part the way the Fed
changes interest rates in my view is
it's for the most part misguided I mean
I think that the Fed should basically if
I had a mile away I would take the
Federal Reserve and I would basically I
would peg the overnight rate at like the
core inflation rate and I would say that
that's just what it is
no more Jerome Powell saying you know
what do I think the future of the world
is gonna look like it would just be
something automated the BLS would come
out with the CPI number and the
overnight number the overnight interest
rate would change people would Ernest a
retail interest rate a real savings rate
on something like Treasury bills and the
whole thing would kind of be automated
so there is there's merit to
these arguments where people say that
the Fed is sort of you know sticking
their finger in the air and kind of
trying to predict things that they're
not very good at predicting and in a lot
of ways probably you know if they're not
making things worse they're not
necessarily making things any better to
be true that the Fed has never
successfully predicted the GDP of the
next corner
they've come close but I don't think
they've ever actually in like you know
more than a hundred times that they've
done this they've never actually
successfully nailed it yeah I mean I
don't know I predicting predicting the
future of the economy or the stock
market or any of this stuff is super
hard so I don't want to be it's a
peaceful guys but it's but yeah to some
degree at some point though you would
think that uh you know you look at some
of this stuff and you see how bad some
of these people are predicting these
things you say well maybe we just
shouldn't be trying to predict these
things maybe we should maybe it does
actually make sense to automate some of
these things or you know take them out
of the hands of people who you know just
are never going to be capable of
predicting these things in the first
place for sure and so if we keep going
down this thread a little bit like how
do you think about the world if we
didn't have QE and Oh 809 if we didn't
have QE now like what would the world
look like if the government hadn't
stepped in in these recessionary periods
and interfered it depends I think if the
Fed had done nothing in 2008 I think
that the banking system probably would
have undergone a colossal huge collapse
that it would have had knock-on effects
that would have caused I mean I remember
talking to you one of my best friends in
DC who is an attorney runs a big
practice out there and he said that he
almost lost his revolving line of credit
he has a revolving line of credit that
he pays most of his employees with he
said he almost lost his revolving line
of credit because Washington Mutual
started going through all their
turbulence and he said luckily that the
government stepped in and sort of you
know kept everything afloat but this is
a business that I mean his revenues were
probably up during the financial crisis
I bet because he runs a practice that is
is mostly injury related so I suspect
his business was probably more than fine
and so you have this solvent business
that potentially becomes insolvent just
because the banking system is in bad
shape and so I think the economy would
have been in a lot worse shape the the
hard thing to quantify is with all this
stuff is the counterfactual I mean what
is the are you are you better off in the
long run by supporting these things and
not letting things kind of you know get
worse when they're when you think
they're gonna get worse or when they are
getting worse versus if you if you
actually you know support everything it
does it does it actually pay off more in
the long run to to help people a little
bit get through tough times but does it
does it end up in like be exaggerating
the the boom-bust cycle in the long run
by supporting things when we they should
be going down and not letting the you
know the creative destruction kind of
occur that makes the economy to a large
degree function and I think there's
merit to a lot of those arguments I
really think there is I think that
there's also merit to the idea that the
government should support certain things
that the government there's a rational
argument for the government to support
the banking system when JPMorgan and
Bank of America just don't trust each
other you know that shouldn't you know
my friend shouldn't go out of business
because JPMorgan is a bad business so
it's hard it's I don't really know I
don't really have a great answer for it
because I I don't know what the
counterfactual
would look like and there's no way to
prove it my my inkling is that there a
lot of it is good a lot of it has good
intentions and that in weird sort of
knock on effect ways there probably are
a lot of negative impacts in the long
run that make things worse off and and
have a negative impact that makes the
economy less efficient and I mean you
see this regulations are probably the
best example of things like that that
have good intentions and probably her
aggregate economic performance
meaningfully in the long run and a lot
of government policies like that so it's
again kind of going back to trying to
quantify the you know the the impact of
all this it's hard it depends on what
your your value judgment is of a lot of
the stuff and so I guess when they do
step in right because I tend to think
that what you're saying around like
there's no black-and-white world it's
just gray right so like them not doing
anything at all is probably an extreme
answer them doing everything and just
giving money to anybody and everybody
who wants it is probably an extreme
example so the truth somewhere in
between how do you then think about who
do they bailout who do they provide
funding to and like is that process that
they're currently going through and have
gone through does it make sense or is it
just you know kind of like the Fed
they're just guessing as to what they
think will work yeah I mean god I this
particular environment to me is just so
unusual because I there's no other thing
to me is that there's no one to blame
for this thing so I think it's hard to
look at people even businesses that you
might hate like Airlines I think it's
hard to even look at an airline and be
like you deserve to go out of business
because of this thing or you know any
business that I mean like for instance
firms that did lots of buybacks I think
it's easy to look back at these firms in
retrospect and say you should
been more prudent you know the average
American doesn't have more than two
months of emergency funds in their in
their a bank account you know is it fair
to look at everybody and be like you
should have saved more money in case a
meteor or hit the economy and I to some
degree it's a little unfair I think to
look back with hindsight and and save
that but at the same time I mean this
environments just so unique that I think
the bridge loan type of structure that
the government is trying to put together
I think it makes sense I think that the
government is basically making a bet
that they hope this thing will be
short-term and you know they can provide
this bridge so that people you know
don't all collapse into the river here
and and die economically because they
mandated a shutdown from a virus that
nobody caused the but again going back
to the duration of this thing the longer
and longer this goes on the less
impactful the government is going to be
in being able to support this big the
the whole economy because here at some
point you're gonna start losing the
underlying resources that make
everything work yeah and I guess part of
it to me like as I think through the
bailouts it's like look why are moose
companies immediately run to the
government it's because the government's
kind of the idiot in the room right
they're gonna get better terms than
anyone else it's gonna be a sweetheart
deal and when you look at the bailout
structure at least for like Airlines for
example it was like 65 percent of the
money somewhere on average actually was
a grant and then there was the low
interest rate loans and things like that
and to me I guess part of it is like
again you're changing the incentive and
the risk reward structures in a what is
supposed to be a capitalistic society by
having the government step in in general
but even if they did step in and they
said hey we're gonna lend money or we're
gonna take an equity position and it's
going to be on terms that are
competitive in the market like I still
could swallow that right Nick okay you
know what like that that's fine good
just like an a step over the line is
when they just say hey you know what
we're gonna give you three billion
dollars and get nothing
in return right and then it kind of just
feels like okay like like that one
where's the line to how'd you come up
with three billion dollars you know and
three like you're basically taking
quote-unquote taxpayer money debatable
right but you're you're basically taking
government money they just heat up
getting nothing in return like how do
you think through that I I think the
criticisms of the airline bailout are
really fair mainly because I think that
that was a bridge loan that was probably
just a bad bet I mean how many of these
airlines are really gonna survive this I
mean let's be honest about this like how
many people are really gonna be flying
in six maybe even twelve months these go
these entities they're not gonna be back
at full operations for I bet years and
years coming out of this thing so I
think in terms of the the government
choosing you know picking and choosing
who to bail out the airlines were
probably in one of the worst places to
try to allocate funds just because I
mean I would not be remotely surprised
if in like six to twelve months
United Airlines is coming back to the
government and saying hey we need your
help again and then the government's
gonna take an equity stake and then the
government is gonna get the terms that
you know they can get from like a GM
like the GM ban allow it made sense to
some degree just because you
you've got terms that were so good that
you know even the government can make
money when you're you're going in and
buying a a decent business with a lot of
underlying assets for you know pennies
on the dollar
um this obviously wasn't that the
airline bailout was again they were
trying to provide a bridge loan to an
entity that is probably it probably just
can't be helped by a bridge you know
they need they need their own like
Golden Gate I mean this is something
totally different just because the
industry I think is so screwed well
here's my favorite thing and
I've almost tweeted this like five times
and then deleted it just because I don't
want to deal with all the trolls but at
the same time at the best investor in
the world a Warren Buffett selling the
airlines
we literally have the government rushing
in to give them money hey great point
it's I mean so absurd I mean I think
Buffett was saying in like January he'll
never sell his airline stock and then he
unloads all of it so so yeah I mean look
I although I think that I think the one
thing that a lot of people missed about
the bailouts is that I think a lot more
of the money is actually going to
individuals than people have given it
credit for and it wasn't just a big
bailout of like the S&P 500 and the the
biggest companies in in the country a
lot of this money is going to
individuals and you know I think I
started calculating it out like the
average unemployed person was gonna get
like like 13 to 16 thousand dollars over
the next 3-4 months I mean it's it's not
just they didn't just send a $1,200
check to people and say hey good luck
with that
I mean they they're sending 2,400 bucks
a month to individuals who are
unemployed plus the $1,200 check plus
like four hundred bucks from the state
unemployment so it's a meaningful amount
of money and I think it's gonna be
really helpful and then you know you had
some of these these the allocations that
when - like Airlines and parts of the
PPP obviously were were messy and
disastrous and went to firms that never
you know needed the funding or shouldn't
have gotten the funding in the first
place so it's imperfect I keep saying
that perfect is the enemy of the good
during this whole thing and I think
there's some truth to that just because
it's such a it's such an unusual
environment that I think that you know
it being compassionate about the degree
of pain that a lot of people are
enduring this thing I think is is the
right default view in my opinion in the
short term even if there are some
mistakes there's always going to be
mistakes in governor
programs and I don't want to like you
know gloss over it and be like oh yeah
you know we shouldn't you know be more
judgmental and you know mindful of the
way our government spends money but it's
hard to pick winners and losers in an
event like this for sure if you had to
give the Fed a grade like a B C or D in
the 2008-2009 crisis what would you give
them and then what would you give them
so far in 2020 um see this is the thing
I just don't think the Fed is as
impactful in terms of like the Fed tried
to create basically growth and inflation
coming out of the financial crisis so if
you're gonna grade them on that scale
you've gotta give up like a D or
something I mean it's not a good grain
the growth coming out of the financial
crisis was not good they you know they
create all these big programs that
everyone thinks is gonna create
inflation and and what happens and the
rate of inflation is like one-and-a-half
percent on average coming out of the
financial crisis like you know they
didn't they did not succeed by any
meaningful degree I don't think in terms
of of helping the broader economy and
here's the thing about the financial
crisis that I thought was so so bad in
terms of the way they implemented all
the policy was that I kept saying coming
out of the financial crisis if you're
gonna do something you've got to fix the
consumer debt problem because that was
the thing that really torpedoed the US
economy in 2008 in 2009 it wasn't the
banking crisis was tangential to the
consumer debt crisis so consumers took
on all this debt they bought all these
overpriced homes and then when it
collapsed the consumers balance sheet
was destroyed and to some degree it's
still destroyed it never really we never
really got a big boom in household
credit in fact I think I can't remember
but if you pull up bum like go on Fred
and pull up cm debt you look at the
household debt that number
year-over-year going into like last year
I think it was lower than like any
recession prior so we were still at like
recessionary levels in terms of
household borrowing coming out of you
know ten years after this thing so I
think they helped they helped the
entities that they're designed to help
because that's what the Fed does the Fed
the Fed is structured to help the
banking system and they I guess in terms
of doing what they are designed to do
they did that well but it had all these
sort of negative knock-on effects that
were bad in the long run and so in terms
of you know did they help avoid a Great
Depression or like a financial panic
that resulted in you know like my
friends going out of business because of
no fault of their own yeah they they
probably had a beneficial impact in the
aggregate because of that but in terms
of helping the aggregate economy I think
the US government failed pretty
massively coming out of the financial
crisis and I think they they probably
made inequality worse or almost
definitely made inequality worse they
didn't get money to the right people the
people who needed it and so yeah I mean
I'm on the whole I mean the Fed probably
gets a D and the US government probably
gets uh who knows maybe like a c-minus
because they did it at least a few
things that helped infrastructure a
little bit and a few of these small
programs that you know got money at
least to people who who needed it more
than bankers did and then what about so
far this year it's yet to be seen
that this test is gonna be a long one I
think in that you know we have yet to
see how long the virus is gonna last I
think so far the the government's gotten
a lot more money to people who really
needed it so this hasn't been we haven't
just bailed out banks or anything like
that the Fed programs have been
humongous but the I think again the
thing that a lot of people have missed
is that I mean the cares Act was Hugh
the deficit this year is gonna be four
trillion dollars that's money that's
going primarily to individuals it's
gonna boost disposable income and it's
gonna float people for a pretty decent
amount of time here so again I think
that in a short term probably the right
move and probably beneficial to some
degree depending on you the inflation
there the kicker is in the long run you
know let's say Pelosi passes for a three
trillion dollar bill and you end up
running like a seven trillion dollar
deficit this year and we end up with
five percent inflation in 2022 then the
whole thing yeah we saved the probably
saved off a depression and we created a
you know a stagflation airy environment
that's probably gonna last for for a
pretty long time so pick your poison
they're both neither one is a great
great outcome yeah how do you think gold
and Bitcoin do through all of this like
where do you kind of put them in in this
model I'll be honest I have no way of
being able to value either of those
assets I think my sometimes I sound
really critical of Bitcoin and gold I'm
not so much a critic of them just that I
don't know how to quantify where their
future value would ever be like I can
look at a ten-year Treasury bond and you
know as crappy as that asset is right
now I can at least look at it and I can
tell you well in ten years you're gonna
have X amount of dollars almost with me
or certainty even with the stock market
you can look at the stock park and say
okay you know I like to think of the
stock market like it's a 30-year
high-yield bond basically and so and it
yields like six percent or so per year
something like that if you hold that
thing for 30 years the odds of you
earning your five six percent coupon
from that thing are probably pretty high
so again even with that
I can look at it and say you know
corporations are probably gonna earn a
you know a certain degree of profit and
they'll pay out a certain portion of
that profit to shareholders and so
stocks will do you know fairly well over
the course of a long term time period
you can't do that with the gold or bit
cold one so I just I mean my gut tells
me that anything that is sort of viewed
as a hedge against government is likely
to perform pretty well but I'm not gonna
you know blow smoke up anyone's ass I
really don't know I don't have like a
high degree of confidence in in that bet
even though if I were if I were building
a really diversified portfolio
I would certainly feel you know more
comfortable owning some things like
commodities and inflation hedges just
because if if this thing does last for
you know even a little bit longer than
people expect there's the real
meaningful risk of inflation coming out
of this yeah and I guess how much of
those assets doing well is dependent on
inflation actually occurring versus just
the fear of inflation right like is the
fear more important than actual
inflation or do you have to have the
inflation to get those assets to really
perform not really I mean look gold is
done just as well as stocks have over
the last 20 years basically um so you
know and inflation has basically been
going down over that whole period so um
you know I don't even think you you
necessarily need inflation as much as
you need you do need a belief set to
support these things more than us if
Pete leave that Bitcoin is going to
become a really viable form of money in
the future then yeah people will bid it
up
so there's they're interesting assets to
me in large part because they're they're
almost
or belief based to some degree than they
are at least at this point then they are
fundamentally based I mean bitcoins a
good example because Bitcoin you know
Bitcoin does have a lot of use cases yet
it's not really hugely widely adopted as
a form of money or anything but if you
believe that it will be and it slowly
does evolve into that thing that you
believe it will become it will become
more valuable over that time period the
question is is you know will will those
things actually unfold I mean at some
point the rubber meets the road right I
mean at some point if you don't get
inflation then you know gold should not
be viewed as a as the heads that a lot
of people are expecting it to become or
if you view Bitcoin as a as a viable
form of money and it just never really
takes off as a widely used form of money
then you know the use case obviously has
failed so but yeah it's super
interesting too because you see central
banks around the world really going
after gold right and they've been doing
that for the last couple of years and
one of the questions I have and I don't
know the answer is at what point if at
all do they say hey we should put some
Bitcoin in here with our gold right or
do they just never get to that point but
but those central bank reserves it's
really interesting to see who
stockpiling gold and who's not yeah you
know the whole Fed coin thing and the
the Bitcoin aspect of a Federal Reserve
seems kind of no it's almost
antithetical to me that for a central
bank to start trying to use a sort of
decentralized
payment system like that it's just the
whole basis of of like the Fed and and
really government-issued money of any
type is that there's a central authority
there's a you know there are
institutions underlying it that they
give it a certain degree of credibility
there is a court system that's
ports it there's a payment system that
supports it and these things are run by
things are run by people they're run by
centralized institutions that you know
if people impose their opinions and
views on they can manipulate them and
they can alter them in meaningful ways
that you know could have both good and
disastrous impacts in the long run so I
don't know I don't think that um I think
the two systems in the long run they
they're they're likely to to exist in
the same way that kind of gold runs as a
monetary system that's parallel to like
a government-run system right now where
you're not gonna have one or the other
necessarily win in the long run I mean
you're always gonna have governments
you're always gonna have court systems
people need to be able to enforce their
payments that do that by you know suing
people in a certain denomination of
currency or whatever so you're always
gonna have these systems to some degree
so I think they kind of run parallel and
you know I I don't I wouldn't be shocked
if these decentralized systems you know
gained more and more in popularity I
don't know what the value is gonna be of
that but the certainly the popularity of
them will increase just because there
does seem to be this trend this growing
trend towards the the growth in the the
way that the government is increasingly
involved in sort of everything that
people are uncomfortable with yeah the
one thing you said earlier that it took
me a long time to kind of wrap my head
around this but we were talking about
the programmatic interest rates and kind
of the lack of having to predict what
happens in the future one of the things
that to me as I understood it better
maybe even more shrimp Bitcoin is this
idea of kind of programmatic monetary
policy now the difference between what
you described in what Bitcoin does is
bitcoins not having that programmatic or
kind of automatic decision made tied to
anything in the economy right it kind of
is just operating on its own but the
idea that
it's got this disinflationary monetary
schedule every four years and kind of
all of these elements I always go back
to this idea that I do think a major
trend in our lives is that people will
trust algorithms over other humans right
and you see that with like I trust
Google Maps I don't have somebody when
I'm lost in a city anymore right I trust
Google to tell me the answer to question
whatever the question is does that ever
penetrate into month right and in kind
of monetary policy and then what are the
ramifications of that but it just feels
like that's where kind of the puck is
going the big question is just is money
you know long for the ride or is money
so sacred and so much of a belief system
that you need the Full Faith and Credit
of a government behind it
god I mean that trillion dollar question
you know it's to me the the big thing
about a government based money that I
think is really the most crucial aspect
of it is that there is a court system
behind it that people feel they feel
trusting in a in a government-issued
form of money to a large degree because
they can sue somebody if somebody screws
them over and that gives people
confidence is and I mean it at the end
of the day a lot of the stuff most of it
is just contracts were you know like a
debt agreement a debt agreement is just
a contract between two parties to you
know pay someone X amount of dollars now
with the expectation to pay them back at
some point in the future that that
contract is enforceable in a US Court
and so the money to some degree has
value because the the contract is
enforceable and that that sort of
central mechanism gives money government
money value to some degree just because
people have confidence in the
enforceability of the contracts that
they're using and that's what you know I
think the thing that makes Bitcoin
really interesting and potential
I think difficult to adopt as a form of
money in the futures that you really
need you really need stable money to be
able to transact in the short term that
to be able to get people to transact for
instance in an overnight market they
need to know that one Bitcoin is going
to be worth one Bitcoin tomorrow and
you've seen this with a lot of the
stable coins that have have come and
gone over time that it's really hard to
create a stable coin it's really hard to
create parity basically in a monetary
unit and as screwed up as the the
government systems might be the
government's just have in a lot of ways
they have such huge economies of scale
that they're able to create parity in a
currency in a way that a lot of private
entities just have trouble doing I mean
a lot of I mean a money market fund for
instances is a stable coin to some
degree or a stable monetary unit to some
degree in private entities run these
things all the time and they try to they
try to stabilize them and they they for
the most part do a pretty good job but
they they don't ever do quite as good as
the government does because they just
don't have the same economies of scale
because they just don't have the same
income streams they don't the same cash
flows and governments are just such big
colossal entities especially one like
the United States that they're able to
create parody in a currency in a very
very liquid and somewhat easy manner
that gives people confidence that one
dollar is worth one dollar I mean in
nominal terms I mean one dollar is
always going to be worth one dollar
tomorrow and you don't really have to
worry about that and that's what makes
it's what makes the decentralized aspect
really fascinating to me from sort of a
nerdy monetary aspect is like can a
decentralized entity ever actually
achieve that because I think it's such a
crucial aspect of of people having the
competence to utilize any form of money
in the short term yeah my
my favorite chart that I've seen in it
is definitely a little bit of a troll
magnet if you will on Twitter I saw
somebody sharing the S&P denominated in
Bitcoin over the last couple of years
and it's basically you know down into
the right at a 45-degree angle for the
most part right but being denominated in
Bitcoin obviously does that when you
then flip it around into an inflationary
currency right it's obviously up and to
the right at a 45-degree angle and the
question then becomes you know the
ramifications of an inflationary versus
deflationary type currency what is right
ten people survive you know can you have
an economy that thrives on deflationary
currency like all of these things I
think there's lots of theories and
people have their personal opinions but
the other day we actually don't know
right I mean that's one thing yeah I
always wonder about that with Bitcoin so
like if let's say Bitcoin became really
widely adopted I I wonder sometimes
would it would it have an inherently
deflationary underlying basis to it
still or would it you know if you reach
sort of an equilibrium where it was
really widely adopted and let's say it's
some you know value of like a million
dollars or whatever it is and you know
you reach some sort of stability point
with Bitcoin as a as a form of money
would it continue to be an inflation
hedge or would people utilize it then in
the same way that they utilize a dollar
and that it would be viewed as a you
know almost a stable monetary unit that
you just exchange goods and services for
them that's the I mean that's the kicker
why is like why does government money
inherently inflationary because it's
fixed at par I mean the government does
have been provide an inflation hedge
they basically say one dollar is worth
one dollar and the trade-off is you know
you have to produce things in the short
term that you have liquidity for so we
have a stable monetary unit that people
can use in the short term and in the
long term
we hope to produce things that will will
basically protect us from some form of
inflation in the long run we have the
underlying resources using these short
term contract to protect us in the long
run and that's basically like a stock
certificate is basically an inflation
protection hedge because it's it's cash
flows are connected to the underlying
resources that make the short-term money
viable so you like a basic premise of
asset allocation is you want to own
inflation hedges because you always need
the short term liquidity component of a
portfolio everyone needs to hold cash to
some degree whether it's just for
emergency purposes or you know stock
buybacks or whatever but everyone needs
a short term part of their portfolio and
you need to hedge that with the part
that is going to have an inherent
inflation hedge which is the part that's
attached to real resources to some
degree it one and here's the part to me
that again this is an evolving kind of
train of thought for me as I think about
Bitcoin and kind of where it could go
and what the ramifications of that are
but if you do have a deflationary type
asset not only do you get a stable value
you actually get a value that has an
opportunity cost of spending it right
because it's gonna get more valuable
over time and so what you do is you have
the exact opposite effect of an
inflationary asset right currency the
whole point of spending the cash is cuz
it's gonna be worth less in the future
on a purchasing power basis although it
doesn't happen quickly well if you
reverse that and you say actually this
thing you're about to spend is gonna be
worth more then you you really changed
this from a consumption type economy to
something else right and I think that
that's where a lot of people point to
something like the Great Depression and
and kind of all of these different times
word had deflationary periods and you
know it ultimately comes down to I think
money is a belief system and it is gonna
be what do you believe it right do you
believe in a government the Full Faith
and Credit of it and the military power
kind of that poor value and all that
stuff or you end up leaving in this kind
of programmatic transparent monetary
policy it is a wild and somewhat out of
left field or off the fairway type idea
today I think a lot of people in Bitcoin
think hey that's gonna become more
consensus over time but that's the risk
you're taking right is that it may never
do that and therefore you end up in left
field and everyone's like hey man the
rest of the financial system kind of
continued on its way like what do you
guys do it yeah listen a four week
before we wrap up what is the most
important book you've ever read the most
important book I've ever read that's a
big question
um cops financial or non-financial I
mean I was saying you know god I mean my
favorite book just from a personal
perspective is uh it's probably demand
search for meaning I just to me the
whole Viktor Frankl story in in
Auschwitz in the the thing that really I
think had a big impact on me from that
book was this whole idea that no one
else can really determine your mindset
about things that no matter what your
circumstances are you can you still have
the ability to choose to have a certain
perspective about you know how good
things are how bad things are and I
don't know for me I think especially
being in in like the financial arena you
know you have so many conflicts of
interests and so many people that are
sort of trying to create competing
narratives and perspectives that it's
it's important to sort of be a really
independent thinker and not necessarily
get too attached to like any type of
mentality and not be not be really
impacted or biased by other people's
opinions too much and not let them steer
the way you believe and view the world
no you could say that ten times more so
people hear you because I couldn't agree
more and and and it's look it's funny
right I mean look I've had the pleasure
of interviewing an incredible number of
people and here a lot of you know macro
investors and things like that and I
tell people all the time that my two
biggest takeaways are one obviously
these people are intelligent but but
also how clear-headed they are how much
in control of their emotions in
psychology and when you talk to somebody
who has that ability what you realize is
that's what ultimately gets them to
original thought right and kind of
independent one of the things that's
interesting with people who really at
least I find people who really
understand money and finance they they
have a good perspective of how money is
sort of tangential to the real world and
the things that really are important in
life and because a lot of people you
know weirdly think that money is the end
and that the money is the thing that
makes everything better and a lot of
people you know it's funny just going
through a whole you know career in
finance and stuff you just sort of
realized that the the money is just sort
of a means to an end and it's not
necessarily the you know the the end-all
that you know I've it's funny I got into
finance because my I never forget it I
was done my brother's graduation and I
had to pick my major yet and he said
what are you gonna major in and I was
like I don't know I might do like
marketing or something he was like go
into finance it's where the money is and
I was like okay and then I get so then I
get into this business like you know
just greedy and expecting to get rich
and all this stuff and slowly over time
you sort of the more you start to learn
about it you're like wait a minute you
know like it's not necessarily
completely wrong but it's a little bit
backwards I couldn't agree more man
we're on where can we send people to
learn about more about you and kind of
what you guys are doing so my company
sadie's or cam group that's my asset
management firm
I write usually once or twice a week on
pragmatic capitalism blog it's Prag
Capcom and my twitter is just Colin
Roach Austin Manuel listen I I
appreciate you being so gracious with
your time I think people are gonna learn
a lot from this and I'm glad that Adam
Singer suggested we do this because I
learned a lot and it's one of these
things where this system is so complex
that yeah every single time I speak with
somebody you learn more and also it
forces you to kind of question every
belief that you held before right oh
yeah I mean that's the crazy thing about
it though the whole business humbles you
in the long run I mean I you know you
get into this whole business arrogant
and thinking you know everything and
then the deeper and deeper you get into
it the more and more you realize you
don't know anything it could not be more
true alright my friend thank you very
much we'll do this together in the
future yeah thanks a lot of Anthony